ó ó hora boa tarde a todos
antes mais dizemos que hoje pretende
provocar das conferências anteriores já
viram sou um homem de ciência não é
visto a sério engenhoso
depois vem o joão e fazem terceiro virá
os originais dessas casas dani e para
não seguir o exemplo da joana joana não
se metem com os sapatos quando há tanta
mulher mensal cai bem isto tenho medo
não é porque eu venho só coisas sérias e
o carlos moura começar a usar com as
usinas que eu ia falar não é e não é das
proteínas e outras linhas
então e hoje tem aqui uma partilha para
fazer convosco disseram eu via contar a
história da minha vida e que devia
tentar com ela inspirar qualquer coisa
porque estamos num táxi eu vi e vimos
inspirar os jovens e eu decidi trazer
vos a minha vida ok é este sou eu e
vamos dizer três grandes ativos que
conseguiu ao longo da vida e depois vou
explicar como é que o capitão está aí o
primeiro ativo e me ajuda a explicar
estas fotos todas segundo ativo rambóia
quem nunca foi campanha ninguém
bom é um termo que se usa muitas ou
diesel s1800 no instituto politécnico
iria com muito prazer e este é o segundo
ativo que eu queria eo terceiro ativo
foi o hedonismo jogos explica como é que
o estudo os converte em ativos
mas para isso eu digo vos qual é o meu
maior problema eo meu maior problema nas
quando eu começo a falar com os meus
alunos do 1º ano segundo ano e isso faça
todos os que estão aqui alguns alunos
meus e aí os meus parabéns que está aqui
uma aluna minha com garantiu hoje que se
fia e não sendo aquela estatal e ao
fundo exatamente fria
qual é o meu problema é que eu pertenço
a essa geração
não sei se ouviram falar isso
provavelmente não porque eu que inventei
mas inventa hoje é que nós somos da
geração boca doce sabe o que é que tu
boca louça não ajudei mar como é que se
faz um provocador água pó frigorífico tá
feito isso é preciso água quente leite
ok boa mas é fácil não é
o raio do problema é que nós hoje
pensamos que tudo tem que ser fácil nós
hoje temos alunos na escola e dizia
assim o professor achar pisa muita pelas
suas aulas nos que sai com a seqüência é
que não estáva as notas assim só de
pensar pensar em um critério não é
então eu achei que o gerou via para vir
falar como é que nós podemos aprender a
pensar como é que podemos capitalizar
coisas que às vezes parecem absurdas
deixem vencer esta geração boca dos
então eu trouxe os três piscinas do
minas é fruto mina ea oficina fantástico
não é que eu vou falar de ciência irmãs
então é eu já vou explicar como é que
como temos isso em um ativo mas deixa eu
explicar o que quis da dopamina dopamina
é uma molécula um neurotransmissor que
está aqui representado a aol nh2 faça
noé que está com você nada com algumas
coisas que acontecem no nosso organismo
principalmente no nosso cérebro quando
nós temos pensar
aumentamos os níveis de dopamina quando
nós temos bem estar também aumentamos os
níveis da família quando temos ambições
ou seja quando ficamos dependentes de
álcool também temos realmente dopamina
quando aumenta o apetite sim é claro por
isso quando nós estamos com pessoas que
estamos temos tendência a cometer um
crime mais comum pra frente ok já viram
que eu faço isso há previsão de erros
quando nós temos uma quebra de dopamina
conseguimos antecipar o erro
o prazer é compensa isso quando eu falar
tô pra mim assim todas estas palavras na
nossa cabeça esqueçam usinas que passem
a pensar nisto quem domina prazer
compensa bem estar é exatamente isso que
ela quer dizer
a segunda é
a serotonina quem anda mais primeiro
tenha menos quem anda - primeiro tem
mais
então e ainda mais ansioso ok bem estar
é nossa memória precisa de muitas
proteínas o nosso bom humor
ok nós prestarmos bem humorados
precisamos ter níveis de serotonina no
nosso organismo dominância social
precisamos de pessoas têm mais duas
meninas são mais dominante socialmente
para a produção se também precisamos
joão para aquela curva inversa também
precisamos que se domina e para o que
nós chamamos e que traz hoje aqui falar
os biologia e neurobiologia da
felicidade ou seja quer que raio se
passa no nosso organismo quando estamos
felizes ou prestaram serviços vêm que
nosso time teve um show à sociedade com
sua palavra final se tratasse toda a
gente soubesse o que é como se vê se
perfeitamente na plenitude é difícil ser
feliz não é nada difícil atingir
aumentar o seu domínio ok só isso
tentamos perceber como e mail oficina
responsável pelos organismos ok
precisamos dela também
mas também para a escolha paris é uma
molécula extremamente emocionada com os
níveis de confiança de empatia e já
viram alguém que vocês prefeitos não
sabem porque confiam nessa pessoa
isso aumenta os níveis dos santos de
oxigênio no organismo quando encara as
flores aumenta os níveis de oxigênio no
organismo quem as vê a segurança
urbanismo
ei três moléculas que vamos agora seguir
vamos perceber como é que elas escolhem
conteiro então eu lembrei dos 13 anos a
fio não isso não há um mapa da
menstruação é isto é um mapa dos 21 dias
ok eu vou ouvir que assumam hoje é que
em compromissos e para isso os votos que
tenham a um cartãozinho destes ok vocês
já ouviram e eu vos prefiro ir em esse
cartão queria uma caneta precisava
escrever alguma coisa e que isso não
hoje aqui um compromisso comigo e o que
eu vou vir é que quem assumir este
compromisso e não estou a mandar
levantar ninguém
lembro quem assumir comigo este
compromisso aqui que o vant com a
esquerda não tem preço ver quem é que
vai assumir
o compromisso de mudar a sua vida o joão
tem um sonho
joão tem um sonho que é tornar portugal
um país residentes
eu tenho outros sonhos é mudar a
resposta que os alunos do primeiro ano
em que revisem daqui a cinco anos eu não
sei que vou fazer professor
eu quero que o meu curso depois pois
olha que vão para o desemprego
então hoje vamos mudar isso ok terço
volta para assumir o compromisso por
favor ninguém boa fantástico
ok mas mantém o cartão for isso os que
não querem assumir podem ficar sentado
ok mas quem vai assumir a implantar
então meus caros é só para lembrar que
está aí uma quebra e vocês estão
gravados ok por isso eu vou garantir que
vocês vão cumprir esse compromisso então
podem sentar novamente e agora escrevam
no vosso propunham qual é o vosso
compromisso para daqui a cinco anos tem
uma filha um papel mas a zona que vai
escrever há cinco anos qual é o vosso
compromisso ou seja o que é que vocês
querem ser onde querem estar sim e
deixem se de tretas
ok a não eu não sei o que quer ser não
sei se posso ser eu não estou contando
isso pergunta qual é o vosso sonho onde
é que sonham estar daqui a cinco anos o
que custaria muito prazer e muito gozo
estar daqui a cinco anos
escrevam nesse tranquilo e depois nos
outros cinco compromissos que vão fazer
abaixo
eu já vou falar lyons e vocês vão se
comprometer comigo a fazer tudo aquilo
que vai acontecer a seguir durante 21
dias
é esse o compromisso dos 21 dias 21 dias
vocês vão fazer o favor de trabalharem
para a vossa felicidade
bom então primeiro compromisso está
escrito os quando nós quer ver quais são
os cinco passos para a felicidade
estes cinco passos são os passos
definidos numa plataforma que o momento
quem quiser descobrir mais sobre
investigação acerca da felicidade que é
o ep fay
o ep faz tem muita investigação
acadêmica científica mas acima de tudo
investigação de vida que vão é muito
ficou esperando a informações
ela 5 vetores com muito suporte técnico
e que de fato quando nós começamos a
explorar os joãos achou que alguns são
fantásticos
então o primeiro e prender agradecer o
segundo é aprender a saborear o terceiro
e aprender a deixar o quarto é zara ea
partilhar e o quinto é enfatizar eu vou
explicar que era um deus e vou escrever
e cinco no vosso cartão
segure a segurar o que tem é que hoje se
lembrou de uma memória fantástica que
teve já no passado ninguém já acorda
todos os dias uma memória fantástica
tiveram o segundo é participar em uma
memória fantástica fronteira seja eu vou
estar a comer num restaurante fantástico
isto é dóro vai ser bom se pensa memória
e esse tem o prazer terceiro desfrutem
do presente fruto do vosso e havia um
contém todos os dias um motivo para
sorrir 5 mas não saiu do gás que vem com
uma caixa cabeça do ex jogador para kaká
este livro não é era eu mas pronto
socializar o brigas socializar com os
vossos amigos todos os dias todos os
dias durante 21 dias
só encontrei o significado das coisas
nada na nossa vida que não tenha
significado vai ter interesse para vós
não encontra significado das coisas
sindical as cartas pode ser fantástico
não é pode ensinar a contarem são ltda
diz que os matemáticos humor réus todos
os dias qualquer coisa para experiências
fantásticas não agradecer diga obrigado
a todos
ok obrigado pelos músicos só não escreve
sem luz não é diga obrigado todos os
dias é vedado sabem o prazer não é nosso
estar aqui
o prazer é nosso porque vocês não estão
a ouvir isso é um agradecimento todos
nós que vivemos temos que cuidar
obrigado por terem vindo hoje obrigado
sem pensar em qualquer coisa que a gente
diz o fundo
escrevam cartas a primeira mão pronto
pode ser meio
escrevam alguma coisa algum elogio ao um
agradecimento a quem gosta
vão todos os dias durante 21 dias e
cultivem a gratidão cultiva em porque as
pessoas que por norma agradecem estão
gratas das coisas são 25% mais felizes
do que as outras que desejem joão existe
israel ter eu creio que queiram alguma
coisa desejem ter alguma coisa é ter
evitem não sou nem qualquer sim eu sonho
andar uma prancha de surfe mas ele não
estava lá em cima vai cair 10 vezes 27
mas vôo em entrevista em que isso é
possível e tentou imaginar já em cima da
prancha é visualize-se no futuro fazer o
melhor e tenho objetivos na vida tem um
rumo porque não tenho como não tem crime
nenhum conseguirem o seu plano nenhum
também objetivos que encontrei um
significado para a vida aquilo que estou
a viver hoje aqui quando significa texto
alguma coisa a não é giro e tal em
durante meia hora tá bom o que ainda vão
embora ou significa visto que isso vai
mudar a nossa vida a partir de hoje
encontra em significado de e partilhem e
quando estou a falar dar não só falar
dar dinheiro sim com medo do gás que
eles colocaram é isso ok é dar porque
querem dar dar voz a partilhem a vossa
ajuda e aqui estou a melhorar a nossa
sorte só chegarem aqui alguma coisa que
nós vamos escolher já descobrimos hoje
também temos um caminho de santos quando
fazemos isto eu senti-me científica hoje
é vedado eu adoro o que eu faço e
educação e para mais uma vez nosso
minério por isso está em um caminho já
vou contar a história de seminários
pratiquem atos que vão dar durante 21
dias durante 21 dias façam algo bom
as pessoas que fazem algo bom pra outros
ajuda em um centro de idosos dem ajudem
são 42% mais com isso
reflitam sobre as coisas boas que vocês
fizeram vocês fizeram coisas boas pensa
nisso ele fez isso existe registo de 21
dias e finalmente enfatizem enfatizar
inclui que ouvir sabe o que quer dizer
empatia é colocar no lugar do outro
sentido com outro cento e pensar sempre
estiveram do que estava quando fizessem
se estivesse aí o que custava que me
dissessem aqui
ah e tal esteje devem vir todos os dias
não se estivessem gostava que viesse
aqui um gajo 12 s
e se tu vai mudar a sua vida e estou
fazer convosco a partilhar aquilo que eu
fiz comigo eu vou mostrar o som é muito
importante ouvir é muito importantes o
rio caí porque sorrido vários sorrisos
já vimos isso daqui a pouco vamos todos
um vídeo com o tempo estava ruim nada e
todos riam os usuários daqui e por que
vamos sorrir escreveu que os nossos
neurónios espelho
quem tem a ver com comportamentos da
autoaplicação e finalmente a
autocompaixão seja sintam pena de vocês
próprios mas não os com os nossos
mastiga nisso nos critiquem aí eu fui o
culpado não é para onde correu mal
pronto e vamos pra próxima
assim a frente aprendam a passar à
frente há três coisas que eu como
psicólogos médicos que nos matam e que
não existem uma culpa
a culpa não existe e que o culpado eu
posso perder isso tudo e dizer se o
proíbe de estudo não sinto que eu posso
dar aqui um pontapé sem interesse em ter
um corte penal existe só que ok
segundo problema angustia sua saída não
conseguir fazer é para falhar
não existe só que o terceiro os medos e
as fobias medos das cobras sabem quantas
cópias morreram e quantas pessoas
morreram movidas por cobras quem estamos
a dizer que tem que acabar
então vamos dizer como é que eu fiz isto
primeiro como é que eu cortei a bóia
você é ser se uma empresa e treinar em
outra
como é que eu curti o hedonismo
endocanabinóide sim eu nunca fumei
drogas são tristes porque é verdade são
tristes e então eu tenho que descobrir
como é que eu ia ter o efeito das drogas
sem consumir drogas
já vou mostrar e finalmente é o m e
curtir nesses três neurotransmissores
serotonina é a oficina e da mina
primeiro então eu era menino barshop sim
eu tirava as garrafas voar e essas
coisas todas
aprendi que a precisão dos movimentos
que fazia com que as pessoas não
pagassem mais por noite meu trabalho
aqui o bar também aprendi que servir os
outros com gozo fazia com que me
pagassem
mas isso não mais o meu caro porque eu
gostava do que estava fazendo
quem aprende a ser diferente porque era
a única tirava garrafas/hora panelas
atrás e talvez porque alguns toques bom
aprendi isto e era o fato de ser
diferente já tenham valor de frente por
exigir outras coisas
aprendam que o movimento não podemos
aprender ser diferente
aprendi também surgiram fazia sorrir e
comandava as vendas do do meu pai eu
vendia 700 shot por noite uma noite eu
sozinho cada choque que estava dois
euros e meio e eu ganhava 50 euros por
noite por isso o lucro era brutal foi o
patrão não é bom
aprendi criar e girar network é
fundamental eu sempre valorizei muito
meus amigos eu ainda hoje valorizo muito
os meus amigos ontem 16 falar com joão e
valorizo muito os meus amigos a ponto de
se esperem qualquer coisa ok eu nunca
disse que um homem que nunca conseguia
dizer na onu
estou hoje aqui também não conseguia
dizer que não aprendam que os teus de
organização e são importantes para a
realização de eventos e aprende podia
aprender a tocar violão sozinho e queria
desfrutar disso aprendi que a finalidade
da confiança em um bom resultado então
hoje tenho amigos que permitem ter
sucesso nas empresas também aprendi em
benidorm relaxar e conhecer permitem
entender os consumidores finalmente
aprendi que ser apaixonado pelo meu
trabalho dá imenso imenso prazer e por
isso paixonite por tudo
obrigado